est ce qu'un pompier est un des feux
définition d'après l'office québécois de
la langue française
un pompier est une personne faisant
partie d'un corps organisés pour
prévenir les incendies comme ne
l'indiquent pas la définition les
pompiers ne passe vraiment pas beaucoup
de temps à éteindre des feux 6 % des
interventions sont des fausses alertes
10% sont des alarmes incendie infondées
et dans 60 % des cas ils interviennent
comme premiers répondants pour des
douleurs thoraciques des problèmes
respiratoires des accidents de la route
des chutes des avc des hémorragies des
surdoses ou des accouchements avec 67
caserne sur l'île de montréal
ils peuvent se rendre rapidement auprès
des personnes en détresse
les ambulanciers qui met un peu plus de
temps à arriver donc des soins plus
avancées et s'occupe du transport à
l'hôpital
contrairement à ce qu'on pense sur 100
interventions des pompiers
moins de quatre sont des incendies